foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
each have their own personality and
backstory for example one is into
popular music there is a girl next door
type a more aloof fashion blogger and
another who is into new technology
[Music]
foreign
there's loads of advantages right so the
first one is you have absolute control
of what this person does in and outside
of your grand cons
so a virtual character ain't gonna
commit a crime
[Music]
you're engaging with influencer as a as
a nice person
um but you're you're sort of uh
disconnecting your mind from recognizing
actually this person is really just a
complete fabrication of a big corporate
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]